Hello. This is Sonny calling
from a very rainy Houston, Texas.
Radiolab is supported by dash digital
cash dash allows you to send any amount of
money using a highly secure
peer to peer network.
Skip the bank entirely and
control your money your way.
Dash is digital cash.
For more information,
visit [inaudible] dot org
forward slash radio labs.
Hey, I'm Janet. Boom. Ryan. I'm Robert
Krulwich. This is radio lab this hour.
Our topic is diagnosis. This
next story begins with a dad,
two sons and a question. What do you
do when you notice somebody different?
I heard it from reporter
to Gregory, right?
Hello. Hi Gregory. [inaudible] nice
to meet. Nice to meet you in case.
Just so you know, it took me over a year.
You can sit down and you to finally
get an interview with Byron France.
I'm wondering if the air,
I can turn the dead in their story and
I'm up in his apartment in the South
Bronx. You'll have skills, all
this loose paperwork. Are you just,
are you moving out or are you
moving? It looks bad. Look like that.
Was that messy? I don't want to put
this [inaudible] boxes everywhere.
Crazy piles of stuff. Okay, let
go. Don't worry about [inaudible].
Yeah, sorry. [inaudible] it's in disarray.
There's who? So who is this gun? I A,
I'm a retired electrical engineer. I
work for subway most of his life now.
I consider myself a science
researcher and it's 71 years old.
He's basically teaching
himself onto physics.
That's what all the books and stuff
you see around. I love that stuff.
And he's written this book
called Einstein's era,
criticizing special relativity. Einstein.
I sent it to the New York Academy
of Science at Caltech, MIT, Harvard,
even Hawkins. Still waiting for him to
get back. Most people just ignore them.
These are the rabies of maniac. But then
he points to this letter on the wall.
Yeah. From Neil degrasse Tyson. I know
that name. This major scientist. Yes.
Ahead of the Hayden Planetarium
in Manhattan. Exactly.
Yes. Yeah. And it says,
how dare you. You're just an engineer
and he's beaming. You know why?
Why do you smile when, when,
when you talk about that letter
from Neil degrasse Tyson,
because I know how
foolish it is. Einstein,
they didn't even want to read his
paper. He said, who is this guy up spot?
He just a patent examination clerk.
And Bern Byron banners is a man
who's proud to go against the grain.
The what other people
do. I don't really do.
And that's especially true with how
he raised his son. So now a Gregory,
you're gonna do, uh, some kind of a story
on the manuals. Youngest son, right?
Emmanuel. Okay.
And that's why I'm here focusing to
question him about how he raised his son.
That'd be glad to. Okay,
great. So here's the manual.
Hi, I'm Emmanuel [inaudible]. Amanda,
could you take a drink of water for me?
Just okay. Thank you. No,
it don't take me. Yeah,
take as many drinks of water. He's 28.
So what things are you good at? Manual,
um,
writing essays and making sure they
aren't grammatically correct bowling.
And as you can hear analyzing stuff,
there is something going on with them.
Um, and, and,
and not talking that much. Yes.
Now if you ask dad, he'll say manuals
and excellent student. Our Future,
no balance. It's gonna win a Nobel prize.
You never know, but if you ask Blair,
I'm Blair frown or is that
Emmanuel's half-brother?
I'm about 20 years old and then Emmanuel,
he'll tell you that even as a little
kid, very, very like five years old.
There was something, oh, I didn't,
I just didn't know what it was.
It's a bunch of little things.
Yeah, like if you'd look
at you really weird,
kind of like a doll face expression.
He could stare at me without blinking
for 15 minutes at a time and I would
notice you didn't blink
once and there was a speech.
I did not talk as much as other people.
There was something going on with the
manual, but I did not have a word for it
and so I'm pushed several times to get
speech therapy, but every time he did,
dad would just say, are you kidding?
He may have troubled stumbling and
stammering, but he'll grow out of it.
I started to Blair. You
also started Einstein.
He didn't speak a word til he was six.
He was considered retarded in school.
He would say that this was some
temporary problem that would pass.
I didn't see anything that was, that
was screaming out for attention.
He was doing his work. He
was interested in the Knicks.
We would go out endlessly in cold weather
to the park and it seemed like things
were okay. What about Emmanuel?
Well, I knew that I was a nicer person,
a nicer person. Yay.
And then I was sent
[inaudible] I don't automatically
look at people in the eyes,
the face and stuff, you know.
So as long as Emmanuel was a little
kid, this wasn't such a big deal.
But then he got older,
he was around 10 years old and it was
that thing at the point where I'm on.
The people would point it
out. What did they say? Well,
I have been called, um,
returning and idiot savant,
the n word and stuff.
They lost the innocence
of the elementary school.
Emmanuel would come home with
bruises on his arms. Yeah. Yeah.
It was something that I constantly
thought about and worried about.
I said, yeah,
well it'd be really good for him
to get professional help with that.
Did you ask dad? He said the
problem wasn't a manual. No,
it was all the other people,
the bullies, the group
in this neighborhood. It was hard.
There was constant
fighting right down the street over
here. People involved with crack.
These are big guys, you know,
I felt that it could have been a
dangerous situation. So his solution,
I decided that I wanted to
teach you manual homeschool.
Pull his son out of school. Yeah. And
how do you feel about this at the time?
Well, I, I really didn't know.
Oh, up here. So we're
looking in the closet here.
I thought that whatever
way he's kind of turned in.
This is a binder from one of his classes
that if he got bullied and tormented
and going to school, that it would turn
him further in. Let's see what this is.
But that if he were here,
he could develop along his own line til
he became old enough that they wouldn't
want to pick on him. Oh, look
what we turned to nature. Nurture.
It was a big deal for dad. You uh, hadn't
homeschooled anybody else before,
right? No. I had to get books.
I had to go meet the
principal. He left his job,
submitted a curriculum to the school and
I had to register with the state of New
York, created this syllabus for his son,
great in integrated math course a lot.
And they would wake up each
morning rational numbers, geometry,
do their lessons. Leslie's trying to
leak lateral, trying to have some lunch.
This is the work that he did at home
and in the afternoon they'd go bowling.
Bowling
manual wasn't
awesome.
His Dad would videotape him.
Today is Tuesday, December
28 1993.
It's weird footage.
It's weird to watch because the manual
is such an incredibly good, yeah.
Yeah. You took it out but beautiful
shot. He's always by himself.
Tape after tape of nothing but a
manual. Nobody else in the picture
I would fan to size about going on a
tour and winning some tiles and stuff.
Did you think about
joining any youth league?
Well, kind of. Well,
I vaguely don't about it, but um,
but for some reason my dad
didn't want me to
[inaudible].
Meanwhile his brother is just players
in Canada at a distance. Yeah.
He followed a girl there and one day he
picks a book off the shelf DSM and the
DSM is the a diagdiagnosis
statistical manual mental disorders.
Okay. Then I started just to do,
I guess what a lot of people would do
who could get ahold of this thing is to
start diagnosing all of their
friends like diagnosed my girlfriend,
I diagnosed my dad and
then I saw her right there in the page.
Marc's impairment in the use of multiple
nonverbal behaviors such as eye to eye
gaze, repetitive behavior patterns,
problem seeking, new friends, problem,
being able to understand what
someone must be thinking.
Problems have went down this whole list
and everything seemed to fit Martin
Pyramids and I, I gave this promise
every time he tried to call his dad.
What do you think his dad
would say? Just stop whining.
He'll just go through this and he shot
him out. You basically cut communication.
I know my son,
he would always tell me Dan,
whenever I hand would go,
we're way when I was in adult. What
does an adult mean? Does that mean 18?
Um, um, 20 meaning 20 lesson. Okay.
So he thought as soon as I reached
the age of 20 then I would have these
problems. Yeah.
So did you wake up on your
20th birthday and think,
I thought they made me,
things would change right away,
but they didn't. After that,
a manual says he got really depressed
and that's how things might've stayed
until
[inaudible] heart attack.
Blair comes to the hospital,
finds dad unconscious on the bed,
and he realizes this is my big chance
because he was not in a position to
intervene. And you're thinking,
I'm thinking the first thing that's
gonna happen is that we're going to get a
diagnosis because we're waiting
for it for so many years,
26 or older or whatever it goes,
like 25 maybe he's going to get help.
You know? He's, he has to get
out mean here's the, okay,
2005 so where are we coming into now?
We're at 42nd Street Times Square
Time Square is one of Emanuel's
favorite areas to hang out.
And I figured I wanted to be
on his surf so they're outside.
The crowd is just beginning to arrive.
It was starting to snow a little
bit and rain some too. Yeah,
I think Blair turns to
management and he says, oh,
have you ever heard of [inaudible]
autism? I said,
I highly suspect that you have some form
of autism and I want us to find some
way for you to get it diagnosed. Yes.
[inaudible]
oh, and I said six, don't
be the word it is today.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
Dr, how do I pronounce your
name? FDIC. Yeah. Agnostic.
And pretty soon after New Year's.
And where are you from? I'm awake.
Manual gets his diagnosis.
He goes right on this couch.
I did get the feeling from my beginning
of the interaction that he was going to
meet criteria for autism. And a month
later she told me that I was on the
autistic spectrum. It was official.
Um, okay. Football. Uh, wait.
And so at the age of 26,
finally [inaudible] his
life completely changed.
So I gave him a tape recorder to
record his life. Hello with me venue.
He's meeting with his speech pathologist
a couple of hours a week also.
He's joined this program [inaudible]
and started making friends. Oh, do I say
hello? Hey Jason. Peace
out. Got a girlfriend. Yeah.
Hey, it's me, Emmanuel. One second again.
And there's one lady that I
haven't talked about your name,
Norma.
And we went to central park and
we took pitches and it was great.
But I always say,
I thought that people who are
diagnosed with autism don't this,
the definition is they
don't want to socialize.
Well ms not because I know do want to,
but [inaudible] this
is hard to do. He know.
But here's the thing about a manual.
He's had this whole new life.
He hasn't told dad about any of it.
Hello Haney thing, not the girl,
the friends, the diagnosis. His Dad
doesn't know anything's different.
So how long have you
been keeping it a secret?
It's been since 2005. Right? Yeah.
So basically for the last two years,
a manual has been leading this double
life outside. He's a person with autism,
then he comes home.
Nothing's wrong. Why? Well,
I'm just afraid in the anyone, um, really,
um, believe in,
but he knows he's gotta tell his dad
who he really is and he keeps saying he
will
lemme say within a month soon.
I'm not quite sure we can,
I am a little bit nervous about
telling him about my ass spot.
Maybe within a few minutes or so. Let
me tell him in like two weeks or so.
[inaudible] I mind to tell
him Matha I mean Blair
[inaudible] well tomorrow
maybe one or no yet.
I'm just thinking about it a
little bit too much. I don't know.
And then finally one night,
I just want to say that I told him
[inaudible] I said I really have something
important to say and don't get angry.
And then I told him that I was diagnosed
with Asperger's syndrome and he asked
me what it was and then I
told him is high functioning
autism?
Uh, I was shocked
that w that would be a good way to put
it. So do you think he has Asperger's?
Yes. Yes I do.
When I look at this syndrome
for a lot good parts of it,
it's e manual,
but I never at any point felt that
that he manual was in need of any deep
psychological or psych psychiatric help.
But
I mean, what makes you
qualified to say that?
Just being a loving parent
as I'm talking to him,
we're sitting there on the couches in
front of us on the coffee table is all of
the manuals, notebooks from age five
onward and they're really good stuff.
I mean it's stuff that you and I
would write and he saved it all.
But the question that I feel like I
got to ask her and I just have one more
question on my list if I
can ask you that one is, um,
now that you know that there is
something wrong with your son,
that there always was this
disorder, that it's incurable.
Do you think you did
the right thing? So d,
do you wish that he had gotten
the diagnosis earlier? No,
because I think that he's better
off at this point in time.
Why wouldn't it make a
difference to know earlier?
What's why you're acting so strangely.
I didn't want he manual to get a
diagnosis that would put him in a box,
like a label. And then dad
says to me, remember, look,
I mean if I had let the school
give him some kind of diagnosis,
they would've thrown him in special
ed and say, oh, he's a retard. Look.
He can't even talk. I mean,
that would've destroyed them.
They would cause irreparable damage.
I asked the doctor was
there any truth to them?
If a manual was put into
special Ed, hypothetically,
he wasn't a district seven to five class.
The technical word for special ed would
not have raised his academic potential.
He, he said graduate from St
John's with a degree in psychology.
Kids who graduate district 75 don't do
that. Just to put that in perspective,
Emmanuel comes from a neighborhood where
about 10% of the kids ever graduate
college. And my GPA was
like 3.4 and change.
Wow. And he's got Asperger's. So
now we're kind of in the opposite.
We're kind of vindicating really
what his father did. Right.
Weight in terms of his
academic achievement. His
father did the right thing.
The problem with his dad's choice,
and he had no way of knowing at the
time was the lack of peer groups,
what team he stamped on. It seems like
a cruel choice, but [inaudible] choice.
So if you were your father and you
were raising your kid at that time,
would you have made the same
choice? He did? Um, well couldn't.
Well, if I had known what I
known now,
then maybe I would have maybe
back Tim a little more for me.
You get to interact with others
who were like, I am cool.
Or like I am
[inaudible] [inaudible]
that story from our
correspondent, Gregory Warner.
Craig's reporting is
made possible in part by
the Rosalyn Carter Fellowship
for Mental Health Journalism.
Thanks to them and thank you to Lulu
Miller for producing that piece.
We will continue in a moment.